als wir auch mehdi treffen trägt der tat
farben alle sollen sehen dass er ein
kämpfer ist mitglied einer schiitischen
miliz wir sind in kerbela einem
wallfahrtsort südlich von bagdad ahmeti
ist 24 und wie viele junge iraker
wünschte er sich ein land das endlich
frei ist von krieg gewalt und chaos
so gott will ich habe mir selbst
geschworen dass ich kein glückliches
leben führen werde bevor das land
frieden und glück hat
ich werde nicht heiraten bevor mein land
gesiegt hat und ich sehe dieses ziel
liegt er nach
kerbela ist voller checkpoints denn noch
immer kämpft der irak gegen versprengte
zellen der islamistischen terror
organisation ihh es auch mehdi und
seiner einheit er hat sich freiwillig
gemeldet da war er 18 bis heute kann
sich keiner im land wirklich sicher
fühlen immer wieder gibt es anschläge
wir sind auf dem weg zum camp der
einheit die teil der irakischen
sicherheitskräfte ist vorbei an fotos
von dem kampf gegen denise getöteten
männern kilometer lang hier werden sie
als helden verehrt
ich habe dutzende hunderte freunde
verloren die mit mir zusammen im
schützengraben lagen die mit mir
zusammen an der freud war sie wurden vor
meinen augen getötet
aber über allem steht gottes wille
3800 männer gehören sword medis einheit
zehntausende kämpfer gibt es im ganzen
land ganz offen werden sie vom
schiitischen nachbarn iran unterstützt
mit waffen geld und know how eine
einmischung von außen die die milizen zu
einem echten machtfaktor im irak machen
irak so gott will wird stabilen und
einig sein
wir wünschen dass gott diesem
geschundenen land frieden und sicherheit
beschert weil wir so viel leid erlebt
haben
von frieden und sicherheit ist das land
weit entfernt auch zehn monate nach der
parlamentswahl gibt es keine regierung
stattdessen einen blutigen machtkampf
unterschieden anhänger des wahlsiegers
als sarah erstürmen regierungsgebäude
ihr zorn richtet sich gegen die
schiitischen milizen einheiten wie die
von nach maddie deren vertreter im
parlament sitzen und selbst den
ministerpräsidenten stellen wollen
als ob sie warte in den ohren haben wir
haben sie nach reformen gefragt sie
gebeten sich zurückzuziehen nichts gar
nichts haben sie getan jetzt sind sie in
die ecke gedrängt wir wollen sie nicht
irak das ist eigentlich ein
multiethnisches und multi religiöses
land in bagdad treffen wir junge leute
die auf eine zukunft hoffen die sich
einen unabhängigen staat wünschen in dem
religion nicht alles dominiert einen
ohne korruption und misswirtschaft vor
knapp drei jahren sind sie dafür auf die
straße gegangen allah hat uns zu sich
nach hause eingeladen
sie ist anfang 30 war damals dabei
perspektiven für sich ihren mann und die
beiden söhne sieht sie kaum noch
ich habe die hoffnung verloren
ich habe schöne träume aber ich denke
nicht dass sich etwas ändern wird die
veränderungen von denen wir träumen die
großen veränderungen werden 50 60 oder
auch 70 jahre brauchen viele jahre
design mode hat ihr eigenes atelier in
ein paar tagen soll die neue kollektion
fertig sein als die neuen unruhen
begannen waren ihre kinder bei den
großeltern
ich hatte angst weil meine kinder weit
weg waren daran habe ich als erstes
gedacht mein zweiter gedanke war angst
dass ich das zu einem bürgerkrieg
entwickeln könnte
ihr modelabel ihr engagement das hält
sie hier egal wie instabil die situation
im irak auch ist so sehr ich auch
darüber nachdenke das land zu verlassen
habe ich doch keine wirkliche absicht
das zu tun ich fühle eine verantwortung
meinem gegenüber wir hoffen weiter zu
arbeiten weiter etwas zu erreichen für
uns selbst und unser land und
gleichzeitig möchte ich nicht von meiner
familie getrennt sein von freunden
meiner nachbarschaft ich möchte hier alt
werden und meine kinder aufwachsen sehen
eine zivilgesellschaft die nicht gehört
wird ein land das vor waffen start das
ist realität im irak
gegen das schweigen im land gegen die
ohnmacht der jugend will die truppe der
mellon city show angehen politische
comedy auf irakisch der titel bedeutet
in etwa bananen republik und genau so
kommt dem moderator der sendung sein
heimatland auch vor deshalb hat auch er
angst klartext zu reden
unser problem sind die leute die den
staat im staate bilden die führen das
land das ist der grund warum unschuldige
ermordet worden für all die probleme
während der proteste die hinterlassen
keine beweise also können wir darüber
auch nicht sprechen ein gefährliches
thema
ali fadel ist das gesicht der sendung
und er weiß wovon er spricht sein bruder
hat nur knapp einen anschlag überlebt
für mich ist jedes land in dem waffen
dominieren jenseits aller gesetze in
einem land mit milizen ist es gefährlich
deine meinung laut und deutlich zu sagen
ach medi kann solche ängste nicht
verstehen in kerbela geht er zum beten
in den imam hussein schreien die meisten
jugendlichen erzählt er uns sehr in sein
land so wie er
die einzige religion die ich kenne und
dann die ich glaube ist die liebe zum
irak ich liebe ihre
glaube und politik das war schon immer
eine gefährliche mischung und das ist es
auch im irak ahmeti ist sich trotz allem
sicher dass sein land sich zum besseren
verändern wird der glaube an die zukunft
die hoffnungen auf ein geteiltes land
das ist vielleicht das einzige was ihn
mit all den anderen verbindet